now we're gonna learn to pass the poi
the final move in for this week is
passing the poi up behind the hips so
the player behind me and I flip them up
behind my hips now this is the classic
move that people often make really
difficult by not doing the lead ups
because for most people it takes a must
building some muscle memory to make this
work and the muscle memory you can do
without POI
and it's going to look like this face
this way with me so for me the dome I
turn this way to face my crane and I
circle my hands forwards and I'm really
circling them not to going like this I'm
really circling them so you're coming
down in front of my hips and up behind
my hips and what I mean I'm gonna go
behind my hips I'm gonna turn as they're
at the top then I'm just going to relax
let the hands drop down so they're
circling backwards right Vanis are in
front I can do the rainbow and I'm
circling forwards again and you really
need to do this in the right order the
hands you let them go behind first then
as they're coming up and they're behind
you turn then you just relax and let
your hands drop down so they're coming
backwards and you need to get good at
that so they just go up behind turn
backwards
up behind turn backwards there's a lot
of things that can go wrong at first and
where you will be building the good
muscle memory for instance you cannot go
turn behind backwards that won't work
with play you've got to let the hands be
behind you then turn then go backwards
so it's got to be an order for words
behind turn backwards the position of
the hands also needs to be a certain way
it will not work very well like this
right your thumbs need to turn in and
it's from the wrists not the elbows if
you go like this your poi will hit the
elbows when you add point sir arms are
hanging hands are up behind turn
backwards the other thing that goes
wrong is people go like this they go
behind turn and they keep going forwards
that will definitely not work with boy
it's got to be forwards behind
turn and then just relax drop the hands
in the backwards now thing is you need
to be able to do that ten times
perfectly behind turn backwards
behind turn backwards ten times so you
can really relax with it boom boom when
you can do it ten times from move on but
not until then
so Chris now when I'm working with
people I often play this game you can
stand here we play because the movements
a lot like you're getting somebody to
give you to give you ten behind your
back so face the cranes put your right
foot forwards so I'm because often what
people do it they'll turn like this and
that won't work well so what I'll tell
Chris is Chris you're going to Cirque
their hands forwards and you're gonna go
really slow and if you do it right when
you're in there I'll be able to give you
ten in both hands to go behind and
backwards exactly if he does it right I
can get I can slap ten right so a few
times he's gonna forwards
behind backwards now if anything goes
wrong they become too obvious so say he
lifts his elbows so like I don't wanna
walk your elbows right and people will
do that so you tell them
see if you raise your elbows I you see
your elbows exactly it doesn't work I
want to give him ten on the hands so
he's got to make his hands available
boom right if he does it with the elbows
drop but the hands are moving then I can
give them ten boom and then at the end
the important key is drops now it's
going backwards so when I'm when I'm
teaching somebody or showing people put
and then and then what asset says do it
10 times perfectly now what happens
often is this I go ten times perfectly
and that they say oh yes right yeah now
then I walk away and I turn around ten
seconds later and what are they doing
exactly they pick up their play and they
try to do the moves and then they get
upset cuz it's not working
so let me come back come
I suggested that you do a 10times
perfectly first didn't I maybe this time
do it until you do a 10times perfectly
now of course Chris is obviously been
practicing very well because he's gotten
very good a play very quickly but we're
pretending he's a stubborn student so
then I sneak off and this time he does
it so this time he actually practices
and behind and by oh wait that was
elbows looking too much to try it with
elbows nice and relaxed new or that look
good okay so do that ten times and we're
gonna kind of imagine the cadets so now
we thought now imagine this is number
nine nine nine times in a row that still
looks good yet you know elbows even more
relaxed so really flipping the wrists
nice back and long and say hey that
looked really good that looked like you
did it ten times in a row and they all
look good so obviously that's getting
smooth now I bet you have some muscle
memory now what I'm gonna get you to do
pretending he's a beginner is you're
going to take the POI
you're gonna start here just with them
swinging a little bit and you're gonna
go behind turn backwards now it's a bit
like karate kid' mr. Miyagi because he's
got the muscle memory and what if once
somebody's practicing you can do it ten
times with no POI they add POI and poof
and it worked now what will often happen
though is this it will work but they'll
go like this
oh and I'll come along and I'll say well
what what's wrong and they'll say it
didn't work and I'll say yes it did
and they'll say no it didn't and they
don't have to make a video of them doing
it for them to believe me that it worked
so even if you think it didn't work it
might have worked so if you're going
along and you go the flu you're spinning
just think for a sec okay are the point
still moving yeah if their ploy is still
moving it really might have worked so no
matter what happens keep the pointing
and you might have to do it 10 times to
realize that you're actually doing it so
and then you'll be like no it's oh wait
a minute that is working right and then
you realize oh wait I think I'm actually
doing it oh I am doing it and then
you'll realize that you do have it after
all thank you